review der video preis für oscars
darüber wird hinter ihr habt ihn so
genossen wie wir mega folkerts die
sonnenbrille schützen eine identität es
geht schon wieder los hatte hatte ich
jetzt wieder eure mal verspielt doch
nach jeder tag mit 32 23
willkommen zu einer neuen folge eure
lieblings formats drei kopfball an und
zuerst wollte ich mit den beiden süßen
glühwein cocktails machen und dann haben
wir uns wieder mal wieder über socken
gemeinsam zubereiten und wir haben bei
artikel 13 gesprochen haben gesagt so
was gibt's nicht der partie hielt dem
einzigen paket für alle die diesen
content nicht mega vermissen
definitiv nein
alle infos dazu leute übrigens artikel
13 hauptfenster auch noch unter
youtube.com safer internet auch mal die
beschreibung wenn ihr dann mehr darüber
wissen wollt denn ihr könnt immer noch
was machen über das werk von artikel 13
alles dazu seine beschreibung ganz
wichtig weil die videos gingen viele
klicks märz kurz dem konzept wir machen
drei artikel 13 kollektiv ballern und
zwar müssen sie uns die sprache
verschlagen
sie müssen richtig balance weil wir
youtuber ziemlich de präsent und einen
starken drinks rauchen also wer durst
spiele beginnen
die haben dort bekannte 30 grad kalt
draußen sehr mir war trat so an dem bild
hier vorbei überhaupt stimmt gemacht
dkk wird erst das letzte mal haben sie
meinen kurzen glas vorgestellt und dann
haben ebenfalls offen
gut so zu diesem schluss war das für
mich so mag ich hoffe dass ich rede mit
seinem schnitt na wie geht's hier
eigentlich ganz gut gut gar nicht müde
habe jetzt acht stunden beschnitten ja
ein bisschen war schon mal duschen
demnach um das möchte ich nicht nein ich
war noch nicht duschen und ja ich
schnell rein nicht los
die leute sagen dann tragen wir so mit
stolz dass man es aussieht und du ziehst
eine weihnachten über einen achten titel
ist ein t shirt ist ein t shirt bisschen
t shirt ist ein t shirt ich für
weihnachten kann und außerdem habe ich
tomatenmark breslau
ich würde ich bin ein karneval vergiftet
worden von immer mit tequila oder wodka
will ich kann nicht trainer habe ich
eine alternative chiliflocken zu machen
falls es nicht tomaten und chilischoten
und dann habe ich aber noch der menschen
ein bisschen qualität ist in artikel 13
roth danger schmerz mundhöhlen die
verwandt werden weil unserem hund
gestellt wird und wir darauf brennen
unsere kreativität frei laufen zu lassen
okay ich habe mich dazu später ich habe
mich dazu jetzt kommt mit dem cocktail
besten live ich habe frisches obst
versuchen die zimmerpreise dann habe ich
einmal hier grenadine sirup weil
grenadinen sonst immer okay und dann
natürlich noch ein bisschen
den teig mit vanessa und didier aber es
geht gern wieder zu bei solchen
schnäppchen machen uns meistens weg wo
ich weiß
und wer hass nicht auch artikel 13 aber
hier auf youtube rot rosa romane aus
bananen weil europa und war ein falls
wir weinen müssen und drei sind weil uns
auch nur heute sehr trocken ist
bei einem preis beweisen will
steinhauser noch vor dem gleitschirm
wirklich das zuvor fernste mandeln
zitronen auch mehr weil wir so sauer
sind artikel 13
lasst uns starten wird
[Musik]
im ersten versuch diesmal ein ganz
entspannter folge der leute werden wir
waren auch gerade ganz schön gut essen
ja wir sind sehr voll gefordert jetzt
kommt ein guter abfahrer haben uns alle
so traurig aber habt ihr ja also hat
eigentlich muss man einen plan b haben
betrogen sie mögen eigentlich ist jetzt
hier meine youtube flaschen das ist
bitter orange später warf youtube
einfach mit glas und so kenne ich doch
ich hatte wirklich an karneval sie so
brands das hat pulsiert mein oberer bau
hat kursiert weil ich so sodbrennen
hatte
leute ich hab waschen
barry gekauft weil wir mit allen
bereichen durch uns alle nach russland
schweiz können wir nicht dazu müssen wir
von einem russen eingeladen werden kann
kenwood so ich hab keinen für getränke
kaufen wäre doch was eine chance gebe
man dass ich muss mir das zeug zu nehmen
fasten ist der fall gut weiterliefen
diese tiere auch dass man als wedding
wort passiert man das artikel 13 männer
durchgesetzt dass so ein richtiges weil
er so sweet cray und dann so das traktat
und das paket ist ein richtig so simpel
dass ein partner einfach muss man
richtig die mit gen soja oder crazy
ausmaß versteht ihr das ist wieder den
teufel
das sieht richtig krachen
ich liebe es mit ihr einig look den eine
administrativ angelegter hast das ist
wirklich so soll gegen tschechien
persischer sprache generationen und
holen es natürlich laufen hier mag man
es sagt doch nicht ja europa marineblau
daraus kann man auch so kann man auch so
einfach diese beleidigt ring bitte
einmal die ohnmacht und jetzt muss ich
pokere habe ich glück wirklich alles
klar
er soll ja ein bisschen halloween egal
[Musik]
sie kennt das manchmal ich keinen grund
zimmer mannheimer schloss das läuft
jetzt nicht und ich bin immer noch nicht
geduscht
mach noch nicht fett geworden bin
er ist wach geworden die kommt jetzt
nach klick bei den kosten
ach so ja klar hast du mich gerade
gefragt warum da steht warum ich es
gewonnen
klar ich habe das ganze jahr an einem
projekt gearbeitet doch endlich kann ich
euch sagen ich hätte euch auch schon
vorhersagen kann ich weiß aber ich
dachte wenn ich es euch sage dann möchte
ich auch gleich sagen in den info box
findet ihr den link zu meinem kochbuch
okay ich fange ich habe mir also es war
ein bisschen glücksspiel also
tatsächlich erstmals redet so ein
bisschen was sagte stucki hier sind
zuckersüß und dann war so ein bisschen
glücksspiel was sie drin das war
eigentlich das was so gewusst dass nackt
[Gelächter]
weil ich wollte dieses männchen oder
einfach was da drin ist dann halt
benutzen dass das halten des kommerzes
zeug kinder eier hier uns einem und
kommerz scheiße jetzt in uns rein geht
wir sind das was hier drin ist und
eigentlich waren wir immer wie hier
unten rot fluffig süß fruchtig mit ideen
überall so kleine keime diese sprache
schließen mit den ideen weise und da
sind eigentlich auch blumen daraus
entstanden
symbolisiert durch die münze weist ein
bisschen frischer aber die blumen
verwelken langsam weil es diese
paragrafen alles dabei fressen und dann
langsam genau sich langsam zu uns runter
frist und so sieht schon das ist nicht
mehr komplett gut ganz und ist nur ein
bisschen rot kurz davor stehen geschickt
zu werden und deswegen übelkeit
ich werde durch die post
bei mir ist das gleiche wie bei den
anderen wings bitte ganz durchstechen zu
und unten in youtube blase und dann buch
durch den artikel 3 jetzt kommt schon
besser war schon verdammt teuer kommt
ein cooles aussieht und dann kommt so
der schwarzen locken will der caddy
macht richtig schlucken dann ist da ja
die märkte weiter fest
er ist auf jeden fall bewertung jetzt
bekommt jeder einmal das internet
und jetzt kriegt noch jeder einmal
computer und europa mitten im
städtischen oder was ja wir haben lange
glücklichen videos sind wir nur
praktikanten die kompletten remission
schönen bilder malt ja rein kippen würde
das internet dann ist es okay
und wenn ihr jetzt das probiert und
jetzt nicht mehr aber ins mischt sich
als europa
da ist eine geile auf die heißt schwarz
was ist das wir können da nur nicht
immer nicht erkannt dass ich nicht mehr
so geil aus jetzt ist das internet
inzwischen operiert gerade mit dem
bundestrainer kommt diese menschen mit
der live action keine story außer uns
erwartet dreesmann so wie man es so
dickflüssig dass hier noch luft drin ist
weil die luft nicht nach oben geht also
ist wirklich mittendrin können noch zum
alten etwa eine woche leben drin und in
luftiger hatte als er das konzert ist
folgendermaßen muss ich mein strom also
wir müssen ein bisschen schokolade
einatmen
[Musik]
den schülern ist es nicht arbeiten weil
ich weiß dass gerade probieren sollten
[Gelächter]
die glasigen augen ich keinen bock drauf
ehrlich gesagt
also ich muss ganz ehrlich sagen kein
bob hin zu probieren was ich gesagt ich
glaube würde mein joker für diesen
folgen eben gesagt wird das geld
schließlich hat mal das ist doch keine
so schlimm ist ein platten verkaufen wir
gesprochen haben
ich habe ganz schön viel im restaurant
gegessen kann das antesten
[Musik]
es läuft wie sowie erde es ist so es ist
so dass dieser geschmack ist so seltsam
und verstört also no shit ich hätte auch
in das glas gerade wenn es das von
wasser getrunken hätte einschalten ja
ich habe nie gesagt dass man das ganze
trinken sein
das publikum sterilisieren
mama also damals
ist aus der entscheidung raus kommt mir
jetzt haben wir zwei sehr starke ich
finde mein kann man aber das kriegen wir
ein bisschen zu süß verspricht ich will
auch für dich aber ich gehe es beim
konzept von neben wasser ich finde das
konzept ja ich finde das konzept von dem
aus schöner und also sieht auch hin oder
wir müssen zeit einfach mal so machen
dass leute entscheiden weiß ich bin noch
unschlüssig wie noch nie nach stimmung
gemacht die kandidatin wäsche gucken hat
kelly ich oder kaffee leute ich habe
mein eigen gemacht und deswegen mit
überhaupt gehört war keine gute idee ist
sehen in der folge
[Musik]
[Applaus]
bio
gutscheine es war wieder einmal das
heißt bleibt fahl und die restaurants
herrscht laut dessen wieder talk jetzt
die kosten trägt er die kurzen comback
er den schüler machen
[Musik]
[Gelächter]
aber mir doch bitte mein bruder 24
internet beschreibungen podcast weil
irgendwann das gibt es youtube nicht
mehr an war ich geld und ist jetzt die
nummer jugend anke brinkmann großen
schluck